extinction rebellion a year ago they
seemed to come out of nowhere
agitated fighting for what they say is
nothing less than the future so who are
they really how far are they willing to
go do their actions help the rest of the
world to listen
meet the people set on changing
everything
[Music]
it's 4:00 a.m. in central London okay
extinction rebellion has a wide range of
targets what's got this group out of bed
early is London fashion the phone
numbers on their arms are in case of
arrest and this fake blood as a prop
this is Samantha Smithson a fashion
designer put glue on our hands right now
like before we get there and then as
soon as we get there just do it a thin
layer I think is needed time for the
shows
I did on my college there's nothing
stylish about filling our planet the
police decide on a hands-off approach if
I could miss it I tell you what we want
to do in any way they let me know the
struggle against global warming can be
hard work eventually the activists
conclude they've made their point it is
after all cold we were freezing
the message is more important than
anything else extinction rebellion
members vary in their willingness to
risk arrest and Loman palak Mack Nick
who's just attended court is a committed
even zealous activist one of the
strategies that extinction rebellion is
obviously to obviously long out the
court process as well and try to jam up
all these institutions the police force
to use up their resources on us and the
Samer of the legal system to make them
feel the effects of our protest as
heavily as possible Roman wasn't always
an environmentalist in fact he used to
work in an office and enjoyed flying
around the world but he always felt
something was missing until he joined
extinction rebellion and was converted
took me to like a little back room and
they were like right okay so roughly we
need you to play your hand so door of a
government department yeah myself again
you know I mean after I kind of what he
thought like I made this big step in
saying that like I was willing to be
arrested they're like cool we've got
some plans for you to get arrested if
you want to do that rule of this kind of
crisis situation there is a clear
pathway to a better way out which is
nonviolent civil disobedience and as
historical precedent and people have
done it time and again these huge
important figures that we all know like
Gandhi and Miley for King Nelson Mandela
all these people that like paved the way
for what we're trying to do if we
continue to just abide by all the rules
and let everything roll on as it is
yet the the consequences will be huge
this building had a conference senator
comparisons with Gandhi might strike
some as a bit of a stretch a surprising
range of people's have joined extinction
rebellions ranks this group of doctors
are targeting the Department for
business and energy I think that the
main outcome photographic before he
retired doctor being Jones was for many
years an aura by doing consultant
hematologist from Yorkshire we're in a
state of denial we are destroying our
planet and doctors are caring and
scientifically literate group and so we
want to go and make a big splash and
taking a slow breath in time to focus
the mind releasing extinction rebellion
even has its own version of a prayer
let's remember a love for this precious
planet which nourishes and sustains all
of life remember its majestic beauty its
forests its mountains its valleys and
the waters of the rivers and the vast
oceans it's a short walk to the
department but low enough for an
explanation about how extinction
rebellion actually works the idea is
that people can do whatever they like as
long as it's within the principles of
extinction rebellion and self-organizing
systems and self-organizing groups are a
key part of the whole thing the downside
is that it can be chaotic it's a very
much a mixed bag and it's rather
marvelous
the group finds the right building and
then goes
[Music]
it's not long before the police arrive
and they're worried about the climate
we're going too far from that a lot my
name is no comment but thank you very
much for neighbors the name is comment
no comment
eventually Bing is unglued then arrested
it's exactly what you wanted is you can
resist however you'd like
I wouldn't recommend rushing about
nonviolent direct action training for
new extinction rebellion members this is
a trading for the October event an
elaborate and dramatic plan to shut down
London for two weeks in year old Daisy
riot is leading the workshop you're
faced with a very real concept of I'm
going to be arrested right now and that
can be scary
Daisy was working as a nanny when she
came across an extinction rebellion
protests in April earlier this year that
event brought London grinding to a halt
and inspired her to join the fight for
radical changes not just a dramatic drop
in carbon emissions that have shift away
from consumerism and the trappings of
modern living in order fast cars and big
houses it's because I was told that that
was what I should want in life and that
would make everyone happy but if that's
at the expense of someone else's
livelihood and someone else's life then
I don't want it we're off to Martha's
house at the moment which is serving as
a kind of Art Centre for the October
rebellion at the moment sorry they've
got some really amazing stuff going on
yeah I mean I'm in the art group and so
I sort of work pretty much full-time on
the kind of art and design of extinction
abelian but now we're in like the run-up
to a major event my house it becomes
like an art factory so it's full of
people who I dearly love so it does get
slightly frustrating at times
despite that in extinction rebellion the
art matters which one show more about
what we're about as a movement and we
are nonviolent first of all and we are
about trying to create a new society so
so there's lots of messaging like that
going on at the Roma but before the
October rebellion starts Daisy needs to
go home to Shrewsbury to visit her much
yeah okay nataly's watched how her
daughter's changed in the past six
months and then shortly after that it
went pink yeah and then orange and then
orange I'm sure and then you cut it even
shorter yeah more tattoos a nose ring I
attended musical dare college and
I was hoping to reapply to musical data
University but yeah I realized that as
much as I love that and as much as
that's important to me it's not
important on a larger scale of
everything else that's happening
continues to happen in at only what do
you think of all this that's a big
question I'm very proud of her it always
have been with whatever she's done
really so I worry but um just good she's
my girl that's all really so yeah and I
don't you know I think when you have
your children you have great dreams and
aspirations for them but um all they can
do is be happy and I've never seen her
this happy which sounds ridiculous
considering that you know there's a
crisis going on but she's never I don't
think she's ever seemed more her before
really
time to head back to London
so office preparations for October
intensified the extinction rebellion
headquarters in Bethnal Green it's
funded entirely by donations and there's
enough cash to pay many of the
volunteers their expenses so if he Tate
gave up her job in advertising to help I
think that's one of the big jobs of
media messaging it's making it clear
exactly who that people are within it
and they're not a bunch of us Angie's
elta maybe both white and middle-class
but she knows what she's doing it's fine
in this country we don't get tortured we
do get some food we get an hour's
exercise outside and fresh air so
compared to what most people have in the
world to suffer absolutely nothing I
don't know why people so scared of it
Roman is finalizing his plans and he
isn't worried at all about annoying
people
I think it's an explicit aim to polarize
the public so it's what you want to do
yeah because you want to you want to
force a conversation on these issues
because currently and say there's nobody
that is making people take aside there's
nobody who is trying to like do
something radical that is gonna polarize
people with 12 protest sites across
central London that's exactly what will
happen the October rebellion is just
days
[Music]
as day once is the start of it all it's
a little bit calm here but we're in the
back streets so yeah it's all kicking
off right now in Westminster
from a cafe nearby Roman Pollock Mac
Nick and his team coordinate the action
they used disposable phones to
communicate and they're convinced
they're being watched in George's
message to say like shall we move down
to the roundabout use comes of a failed
attempt to shut down a road Horse Guards
Parade and now Trafalgar Square is also
potentially going to go in a minute so
here's the different sites here's where
there are and this is like they're kind
of like progress so like a as they've
made it let's plan a plan B is they've
had so they try and join another site
and then Plan C is like the backup sites
that we've got and that's just like
we're doing updates of where they are
with the cyclists coming back and forth
telling us where everybody's at was yeah
was that fight take oh yeah how's it
going so far seems pretty good for your
interview Roman leaves to check on
what's going on himself
there's one site left to take and it's
the biggest one I've decided to help out
my fellow rebels in taking the Trafalgar
which is waiting now for the for the
signs of self blocking the other Road I
think one of the greatest things
he's at five minutes this is Daisy's
first major rebellion got nervous
stomach ache
then the man in the orange jacket gives
the signal to move
all right
[Applause]
[Applause]
these rebels are putting their Liberty
at stake for your extinction rebellion
believes in people power but that can
mean chaos and inconvenience for those
not involved
[Music]
for Daisy it means jubilation
[Applause]
all my worries and run away because I
know that I'm surrounded by super like
them now the roads are blocked the aim
is to keep it that way and we feel we
have the resources to hold there and the
team and the effort and there and the
well - then we'll hold it for as long as
as we find necessary as long as we feel
it take for us to be listened to roman
arrives to speak to his team at repel
the square it's not even like this is it
again the same thing every time that
Lemmy turns out at the beginning that we
were able to come plates everything but
yeah it was like gonna be quiet but
doing the loops round now that little
things are popping up you see the tape
there of the Flyers and we've got the
box just coming up here we've got the
scaffolding there as well these are just
one sight
we've got like a number seven of these
going on at the same time right now this
is incredible it's happen again bigger
and better
it's the morning of day 2 and the police
are allowing the disruption to continue
for the moment Daisy shows us around the
camp
this one's mine this little guy I won't
tell you what's in it because of present
company I've got my pillows sleeping bag
I got a map as well roll map they've
made a mini city here an example of what
extinction rebellion calls regenerative
culture it'll be a some kind of
meditation circle this is the art
Bacchus tent where you can customise
your clothes and stamp them with
whatever you want this is the well-being
sanctuary so we've got a little little
schedule up and we'll be quiet
there's a shed over there I don't know
quite what purpose observing yet but
later in the day the weather turns and
with it the moon
[Music]
the pressure builds and the police
decides enough is enough
[Applause]
they start clearing the site's beginning
with this one outside down the street
[Applause]
[Music]
the operation continues long into the
night by the time it ends around 500
people who have been arrested
back near their base in East London
Roman discusses the next stage of the
October rebellion one of the groups
demands is net zero carbon emissions by
2025 that's 25 years before the
government's own gold that makes
aviation and with it the public's
ability to fly a top target City Airport
is the transport kind of mass action day
that we're going to be doing in the
first week so people were going down
there on mass to occupied a terminal
kind of inspired by the recent protests
in Hong Kong yeah it's totally
peacefully non-violently but just a mass
occupation of that terminal to highlight
aviation
but police are ready determined to keep
London City Airport open security is
tight only passengers with a boarding
pass are allowed in then the rebels
strike
[Applause]
[Applause]
there's a gentleman who's climbed on top
of the play very shaky hate Heights
I don't know how the hell I grew up here
I don't know how
again I'm gonna stop this fight under
arrest also put it on your phone I saw
your phone is going to be seized
[Music]
there's dr. Bing Jones again back in the
thick of it I am ashamed of the fact
that intelligent people such as myself
who were educated and who have privilege
and power do nothing
it is quite inexcusable
[Applause]
among some extinction rebellion members
breaking the law is considered a
necessary sacrifice the only way to
confront what they say is a broken
system we can block this bill now it's
Romans turn to risk arrest again this
time at the airport the plan is that we
are going to go and join the mass of
people down at City Airport the moment
I'm not quite sure how it's over with
them but we're gonna go and join them
for a more discreet kind of route on
bicycles we try and block the private
members entrance but I mean we're
imagine it with the police everywhere
it's gonna kind of play it by ear as you
are
[Music]
I'm gonna go gonna stay here
oh she tried jump in front of the cab
you know he fired it up
I would lost my license in my living
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
good Roman has achieved his aim later
he's released on bail and charged with
blocking a public highway Bing was also
arrested again during the October
rebellion and back at Trafalgar Square
Daisy is taken into custody - released
without charge before joining the
protest together they were just three
among the nearly two thousand people
arrested during the fortnight rebellion
fighting they say to save the world but
that fight is proving controversial and
divisive
this an example of Peters anger at a
protester stopping a London Underground
train not everyone is willing or able to
focus on extinctions course whether they
are taking the people with them or not
extinction rebellion says it has given
up asking nicely for change a movement
determined to alter the course of
history and with it the way we live our
lives
[Music]
you